ah
un cambio político histórico el partido
sinn fein se convirtió por primera vez
en su historia en el partido más votado
en irlanda del norte- y podría alcanzar
una mayoría parlamentaria que le
permitiría dirigir el nuevo gobierno de
ese país que integra el reino unido
junto con inglaterra gales y escocia sin
fin es un en su momento fue el brazo
político del grupo irá es de tendencia
republicana por años movió las banderas
de la reunificación de su territorio con
la república de irlanda décadas atrás
bajo su dirección católicos
proirlandeses combatieron contra los
lealistas protestantes probritánicos
pero durante la más reciente campaña sin
fin evitó abordar la cuestión de la
unificación y se concentró en temas que
eran prioritarios para los ciudadanos
como los temas sociales el desempleo el
crecimiento económico y la salud pero
después de los comicios la líder del
sinn fein michel o'neal ha llamado a un
fuerte debate sobre la unidad de irlanda
pero más allá de ese debate la prioridad
ahora mismo en este momento en ese país
es la formación de un gobierno
partido más votado designa al ministro
principal del ejecutivo autónomo
mientras que la segunda formación en
número de apoyos nombra al viceministro
principal los cargos tienen
prácticamente la misma importancia así
por lo menos lo indican los acuerdos del
viernes santo de 1998 lo que buscan es
un equilibrio de poderes y que tanto
católicos como protestantes tengan que
ponerse de acuerdo a la hora de gobernar
pero el dv que es el partido democrático
unionista ya dijo que no formaría
gobierno hasta tanto no vaya a una fecha
para una nueva de negociación del
protocolo de irlanda el protocolo de
irlanda es ese acuerdo alcanzado entre
londres y bruselas para materializar el
break city y así evitar levantar una
frontera entre las dos irlandas porque
precisamente los acuerdos del viernes
santo- impiden cualquier tipo de
frontera entre esos dos territorios a
grandes rasgos pues eso es más o menos
el panorama político actual en irlanda
del norte en unos minutos vamos a
profundizar pero como ha llegado hasta
esta instancia el sinn fein después de
años de guerra y de conflicto se lo
explicamos a continuación
10 de abril de 1998 el acuerdo del
viernes santo- pone fin al conflicto en
irlanda del norte
los enfrentamientos entre los unionistas
protestantes junto al ejército británico
por un lado y los republicanos católicos
por otros se sucedieron durante tres
décadas un conflicto territorial y
religioso que tiene sus raíces en la
partición de irlanda en 1921 cuando seis
condados del norte de la isla
permanecieron dentro del reino unido- en
la actualidad los dos millones de
habitantes de irlanda del norte están
divididos casi a partes iguales entre
católicos y protestantes el 30 de enero
de 1972 sucedió el domingo sangriento
cuando los soldados británicos abrieron
fuego contra una manifestación en derry
matando a 14 personas convirtiéndose en
un símbolo de la causa republicana
norirlandesa el ir a el ejército
republicano irlandés se embarcó entonces
en un ciclo de violencia y ataques como
sus enemigos unionistas no fue hasta los
acuerdos de 1998 cuando el sinn fein la
rama política del irá comenzó a jugar el
juego democrático dentro de la nueva
asamblea de belfast en 2005 el ira
acabaría abandonando oficialmente las
armas
dos años después junto al partido
unionista democrático dup el sinn fein
participó por primera vez en el
ejecutivo de irlanda del norte en la
persona del antiguo líder del ira martin
mcguinness los partidarios del
permanecer dentro del reino unido han
sido la primera fuerza política hasta
2022 pero el break sheet ha socavado
esta nueva paz porque el acuerdo del
viernes santo- prohíbe cualquier
frontera física entre irlanda e irlanda
del norte y con el break city se puso en
duda los europeos prevén el control
aduanero de las mercancías que pasan
entre irlanda del norte y el resto del
reino unido- un protocolo que ha sido
muy criticado por londres y los
unionistas hasta el día de hoy y que ha
provocado graves trastornos de la cadena
de suministros de irlanda del norte los
precios se dispararon y la sensación de
estar abandonados creció entre la
población en la primavera de 2021 los
barrios protestantes estaban en llamas y
hubo enfrentamientos entre algunos
jóvenes y la policía una señal de que el
conflicto sigue vivo en la mente de la
gente en belfast los muros sirven
separando a los republicanos católicos y
a los unionistas protestantes
bueno pues para este pasado tan convulso
que ha vivido irlanda del norte uno
pensaría que dado el contexto actual en
el break city y lo pensaría uno que tal
vez la la alternancia política parece
ser saludable para la política de ese
país por más de cien años gobernaron
protestantes que apuestan por mantener
ese estrecho nexo que los une con el
reino unido pero qué futuro puede
esperar irlanda del norte con un
parlamento en donde la fuerza con más
escaños representa otro tipo de
intereses la líder del sinn fein michel
o'neal da algunas luces al respecto
escuchamos de otros en año y verón hoy
se inicia una nueva era creo que nos
brinda a todos la oportunidad de real y
marginar las relaciones en esta sociedad
sobre la base de la equidad sobre la
base de la igualdad y sobre la base de
la justicia social independientemente de
los antecedentes religiosos políticos o
sociales
mi compromiso es hacer que la política
funcione realmente es tim holt sexual
bueno tema muy profundo con múltiples
puntos para analizar qué significa
entonces el triunfo de sinn fein para la
política norirlandesa existen las
condiciones para un posible referendo o
de independencia de este territorio del
reino unido mucho se está especulando
sobre eso que peso ha recaído entonces
sobre irlanda del norte tras él preside
gracias al protocolo firmado entre
londres y bruselas que logros
catapultaron al sinn fein hacia la
preferencia de los votantes tal y como
lo han dicho en las urnas en días
recientes cuál fue la estrategia que
papel tiene su actual líder michele
o'neal lo vamos a analizar en el debate
de france 24 y para analizar ese tema
saludamos al doctor daniel nin a él es
jurista y científico social docente de
la universidad de puerto rico está
conectado vía telefónica desde la ciudad
de san juan y desde londres se aúna esta
conversación eba millán ella es analista
internacional también es corresponsal en
el reino unido e irlanda para la cadena
española antena 3 ella se encuentra
conectada desde la ciudad de londres
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas los pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram y
en twitter estamos como france24 bajo
ese arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra ticket es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este tema comienzo entonces con eva que
está conectada desde la ciudad de
londres la capital británica
preguntándole como punto de partida para
el debate iba primero que todo
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos y cuál es el balance que
usted hace de esta campaña de este
proceso democrático en el que el sin fin
resultó triunfador en estas elecciones
regionales
bueno lo primero buenas tardes lo
teníamos bastante claro porque los
sondeos habían apuntado ya a que era
inevitable esta victoria del sinn fein
esta victoria histórica era imparable
era una nueva marea y una marea de
cambio este cambio sin embargo por
primera vez no está tan relacionado con
la cuestión que siempre a manning 1 x
izado la vida en irlanda del norte que
es la continuidad del dominio británico
en irlanda del norte o un cambio
atreverse a pensar en un futuro
potencial en el que el reino unido no
tenga voz ni voto ni presencia y que sea
un territorio completamente
independiente del gobierno británico en
este caso a pesar de la vitro del sinn
fein no lo ganó por esta promesa es
decir no fue la posibilidad de un fin de
ser reinado de reino unido que habíamos
visto durante tantas y tantas décadas y
que ha causado tantos enfrentamientos
por las dos partes sino que el sinn fein
tuvo una estrategia muy inteligente que
también la había probado en irlanda es
decir en la república de irlanda la
parte que sí es parte de la de la unión
europea que es la de
adaptarse relativamente de ese discurso
anterior y meterse en la política pura y
dura y cuál es la política el coste de
la vida y la necesidad de una sanidad
mejorada la vivienda es una cuestión que
el sinn fein ha sido muy muy inteligente
a la hora de vender la necesidad de
garantizar un acceso mejor a la vivienda
cuando es uno de los grandes problemas
en irlanda del norte y también en la
república de irlanda con lo cual lo que
hemos visto realmente ha sido ese giro
por parte del sinn fein que ha tenido la
audacia de entender que si quería
recabar tenía que dejar un poco el
discurso del pasado y meterse en
política real porque realmente es que el
sinn fein ya era parte del gobierno con
lo cual ya no eran los outsiders de de
hace 15 años por ejemplo cuando se
planteaba la posibilidad de un gobierno
conjunto a partir de esos acuerdos del
viernes santo que comentaba jce están
tan buenamente en el vídeo
el doctor daniel mina le ve también la
bienvenida al programa y también la
misma pregunta como punto de partida
para este análisis su balance de esta
campaña de este proceso democrático hay
en irlanda del norte y lo que usted
puede interpretar de este triunfo de
sinn fein hay en irlanda del norte si
muchas gracias por limitación aquí
deseamos de puerto rico me expuso con la
cámara pero creo youtube en febrero en
belfast y fui allí a ver a mi vieja mica
sabíais un trabajo en la fin de la
década del 90 luego del acuerdo de
viernes santo
y vuelvo 20 años después y me encuentro
como dice la compañera que en el
programa conmigo que la política de los
pragmáticos se empezó a imponer por algo
curiosísimo sinn fein descubre que la
modernización el desarrollo
socioeconómico en bienestar de su
población católica pero también de la
protestante y otros se alcanzaba mejor
dentro de unión europea que fuera la
unión europea y según detalle bastante
interesante lo que uno descubre allí
cuando habla con persona vieja amistades
que han dedicado todas la lucha que una
vez se empieza a dar la salida de
inglaterra al resto el preside y
empiezan a mermar los fondos públicos
que venían de la unión europea decir de
bruselas que habían adelantado mucho
desarrollo socioeconómico allí la gente
se empieza a resentir y esto a mí me
parece interesante porque un tipo de
colonialismo pragmático que busca otra
relación la diríamos nosotros esta forma
de integración a otro mercado de
desarrollo socioeconómico donde
inglaterra y la política de aislamiento
británico para ellos se convierte en una
bandera de lucha es decir la unificación
con irlanda la república en este momento
puede promoverse para mantenerse entre
la unión europea vis-à-vis y el
contrapunto y esto se de el contrapunto
de salirse y estar con inglaterra
marginado o con otro tipo de proyectos
socioeconómicos y eso a su vez este mal
que se marca entonces con el partido
unionista que llega según lo que había
estado liderando antes que se queda sin
proyecto político en otras palabras el
proyecto por el dinero también se había
beneficiado a la reunión con el mercado
de la unión europea en los beneficios
que se traía en desarrollo puntual de
sociedades que hubieran llegado mucho
desarrollo puntual que la gente se haya
beneficiado y es una reacción un poco en
un pragmatismo político y de mantención
vamos en unos minutos ya analizar ese
tema de esa posible unión de ser
referendo que tanto se estaba comentando
ese posible retiro del reino unido que
muchos especulaban los medios de
comunicación en los últimos dos días
quiero preguntarle al doctor daniel ya
le voy a dar la palabra e va solo para
hacer la ronda la inversa sobre el
simbolismo que tiene que sin fin se
ahora el partido político con la mayor
cantidad de escaños en el parlamento de
irlanda del norte ya veíamos el contexto
de la lucha armada que se ha librado
allí en el contexto que vivieron a lo
largo de las negociaciones y lo que está
viviendo irlanda ahora después del break
sheet que significa para la política de
este país que sin fin tenga más escaños
en el parlamento
significa que el ministro principal
podría ser la compañera o'neal y dentro
de los acuerdos de paz de 1998 y la ley
de irlanda tendría que ir de la mano con
el candidato del segundo partido en el
partido unionista los cuales al momento
están diciendo que no va a conformar esa
sí que va a haber una crisis
constitucional interesantísima si ella
acepta el puesto pero el otra parte no
la acepta no sé cómo se resolvería eso
en este momento porque técnicamente eso
es lo que dice en los acuerdos la
voluntad popular que es algo que por lo
menos en mi experiencia cuando estuve en
irlanda a fines de la década 90 y cuando
se hagan los acuerdos como lo
proyectaban es que era un problema de
generaciones porque la población
católica tiende a crecer más que la
población protestante y ellos habían
marcado que en 1520 años iba a haber un
cambio demográfico que le iba a permitir
ganar la sunass del poder eso tal parece
que será ahora en el 2022 estoy en la
esquina donde esté pronosticando pero es
interesante esa idea de lo que era una
tendencia demográfica que tiene un
resultado claro más allá del simbolismo
por lo menos y con esto termino el
simbolismo histórico del momento de la
partición en 1921 y ahora la posibilidad
que por primera vez los católicos que es
una población real en la irlanda del
norte puedan dirigir pues a los que
hemos creído en esa tendencia pues algo
muy interesante pero no sin lugar a
dudas se puede excluir que hay otra
población que no piense igual y que
existe lo que pasa que el modelo
irlandés para mí y yo vivimos en
sudáfrica y visto el de irlanda el de
irlanda es un modelo muy exitoso en
algunas cosas que tuvo con tuvo la
violencia y eso para mí es muy
importante para que la gente
racionalmente hable y llegue por proceso
electoral a una posición u otra el
proceso irlandés ha sido exitoso en ese
sentido exitoso en ese sentido eba
opiniones sobre este punto sobre el
simbolismo que tiene que sin fin llegue
al parlamento con mayoría de escaños
cuál es su opinión
pues es muy similar a la que comentaba
el doctor porque efectivamente es una
cuestión generacional hay que pensar que
hay muchísimas generaciones de votantes
que no vivieron lo que se llama los
tragos que son esos años en los que
había habido pues los asesinatos
constantes de vida es decir no ha habido
una destoxificación del ira pero el ira
lógicamente ya no existe como existía sí
que es cierto que hay ciertas
actividades paralelas y paramilitares
que conjuntamente continúan y que a raíz
del brazil pues se ha se ha continuado
incluso ha empeorado la situación pero
efectivamente habido un cambio
generacional ya nosotros porque los
católicos sean mayores sino porque en
los dos bandos efectivamente hay muchos
votantes que llamamos sufrieron eso ya
raíz de eso pues ya no es impensable que
un votante ya no diría unionista pero
que alguien que ya no está militando a
ninguna de las dos áreas ni unionista ni
republicano que esa es la cuestión por
ejemplo tenemos un partido que se ha
disparado también estas elecciones y que
es el tercer partido y que dice que eso
se le escapa completamente que ellos no
les importa si es unionismo o ser
republicano sino que es una cuestión de
garantizar un nivel de vida a nivel de
lo que merecen los ciudadanos de irlanda
del norte y esos votantes son los que
están proliferando cada vez más de ahí
que el simbolismo del sinn fein sea muy
fuerte cuando nos centramos por ejemplo
en las comunidades más acérrimas del
unionismo que consideran todavía hoy que
el sinn fein son literalmente asesinos
esto es lo que uno recibe cuando habla
con ciertos sectores pero en general ya
y esa detoxificación del sinn fein y que
es a raíz de que ya no se posiciona
necesariamente todo el electorado en
torno a continuidad en el reino unido- o
ruptura claro además que es una
generación que ha vivido prácticamente
lo mejor de los dos mundos vivió
toda la recuperación del país después de
los acuerdos vivió lo mejor que le pudo
ofrecer el reino unido desde londres
pero también vivió ese milagro económico
que ha tenido irlanda dentro de la unión
europea ese crecimiento importante y
destacado vivió prácticamente en la
mitad de los dos mundos y tiene una
visión que creo que pocos países tienen
de lo mejor que puede tener cada una de
las partes y va a continuar con usted
allí en la ciudad de londres para
terminar este tema electoral y cómo
están los partidos allí como usted
entenderá en américa latina' un tema muy
ajeno y me toca meterme con preguntas
muy muy minuciosas y quiero que nos
cuentes sobre el partido democrático
unionista dup que muchos pronosticaban
una debacle electoral que iba a ser una
gran caída a nivel político después de
estas elecciones pero se quedó con 25
escaños son solamente tres menos de los
que ya tenía y si pierde esa primera
posición pero pero sigue siendo un
partido fuerte entonces en el parlamento
y efectivamente se hablaba como decías
de una debacle solo a partido tres y
estás solo dos por debajo del sinn fein
esto no lo que nos revela ante tú es una
irlanda del norte completamente dividida
a la mitad en si lo analizamos desde el
punto de vista del unionismo o
republicanos pero a partir de ahí su
poder es muy poderoso muy fuerte porque
son los que pueden decidir si
efectivamente va a haber gobierno o no
porque los acuerdos de viernes santo lo
que establecieron las que tienen que
dividirse el poder independientemente de
los resultados tiene que compartir el
poder el que tenga más escaños
es el ministro principal que es el
equivalente a un primer ministro o un
presidente en este caso no es de la
república porque lógicamente vivimos en
una monarquía pero es el que es el la
mayor torpeza del gobierno el del
cultivo
efectivamente el jefe del ejecutivo del
número 2 pues en grados del ejecutivo
esto está establecido unos acuerdos de
viernes santo press que tampoco tiene
legitimidad el sinn fein para
mantener que sus resultados han sido tan
espectaculares como para que el dub el
itv haga lo que ellos digan porque
efectivamente son sólo dos diputados
menos en qué momento nos encontramos
pues que este viernes hay la primera
reunión de este parlamento y el dup
debería denominar quienes quiere que
sean los ministros en este potencial
gobierno pero ellos han dicho ya que no
porque tienen un programa muy serio que
es lo que se acordó para solucionar la
cuestión del break se liquide lo que se
acordó podemos hablar lo más adelante
pero a partir de ahí ellos dicen que de
momento no van a nominar a nadie no es
que sea sus problemas y fein el problema
es lo que se denomina el protocolo de
irlanda del norte- y ahí es donde ahora
mismo tenemos este bloqueo fundamental y
pasamos 24 semanas información de
gobierno los norirlandeses tienen que
volver a las urnas estamos terminando de
restablecer la conexión con el doctor
daniele ni na continuó entonces con
usted usted ya se aproxima a la
siguiente pregunta que yo tenía y era
estas declaraciones de jeffrey donaldson
que es el el líder del pp que dice que
pues como usted lo menciona no van a
nominar a nadie hasta tanto no lleguen
a una mesa de negociación digámoslo así
para volver a conversar sobre ese
protocolo que pactaron londres y
bruselas esta no sería una forma tal vez
de sabotear le un poco este triunfo a
sinn fein en términos políticos como lo
ve usted
es una forma de sabotear en el sentido
de que pueden jugársela a unas nuevas
elecciones dentro de seis meses y quizá
en las nuevas elecciones lograr un
vuelco es decir volver a ser la fuerza
con más escaños en el parlamento pero
independientemente de los resultados de
estas elecciones
el protocolo de irlanda del norte para
ellos es una cuestión completamente
estructural ellos consideran que la
solución que acordó el gobierno
británico es decir el gobierno de todo
reino unido para evitar la peligrosa re
imposición de una frontera entre las dos
irlandas es decir del reino unido-
independiente post per xxi y la
república de irlanda un miembro de la
unión europea pues pasar la frontera en
la práctica a lo que se llama el mar de
irlanda es decir este estrecho que
separa la isla de gran bretaña que es
inglaterra escocia gales de la isla de
irlanda en la que conviven dos países
esto para ello significa que en rama del
norte se acerca a la república de
irlanda con lo cual ese miedo de la
unificación de repente no es algo
impensable porque desde un punto de
vista normativo están funcionando casi
de la mano porque así lo estableció el
gobierno de londres basado aquí sin
pensar en las ramificaciones que tendría
en su día una vez aplicado el protocolo
de bandas del norte sobre un territorio
que sigue siendo un territorio de alta
tensión con lo cual el dux y puede estar
jugando a política pero para ellos es
una cuestión completamente estructural y
hasta de esencia de lo que es su
proyecto que es el mismo y la
continuidad en el reino unido a pesar de
que ha sido el gobierno británico el que
los ha vendido
ya tenemos otra vez conexión con el
doctor ni na en la ciudad de san juan en
puerto rico- doctor le estaba
preguntando a eba sobre esas
declaraciones de jeffrey donaldson el
líder del pp quien ha dicho como lo
mencionaba ella que no va a nominar un
gobierno oa sus ministros hasta tanto
londres no se siente negociar nuevamente
ese protocolo con la unión europea
porque según lo que desde el punto de
vista que ellos lo ven no les beneficia
no le beneficia a irlanda del norte lo
que fue pactado cuál es su opinión al
respecto
es un poco una metáfora porque es el
colonialismo dentro del colonialismo y
esto a mí me parece el santísimo e
irlanda del norte este que su
modernización está en la república
interesa porque materialmente hablando
tiene un desarrollo socioeconómico mayor
que contra parte de la guerra y eso crea
unos problemas muy interesantes sobre el
futuro lo que percibí cuando fui ella en
febrero era que la salida del presi
había causado un tipo de dis lo que es
biosicosocial si puedo decir eso donde
las dos facciones históricas la católica
y la protestante
veían que la solución de unirse
inglaterra no era materialmente la que
más les viene por algo que dijo la
compañera es decir la gente piensa en
sus entidades básicas en empleo en un
nivel de modernización que tenga obras
públicas que era lo más importante que
los irlandeses del norte habían visto
para el fin de la europea
por los gastos las entrevistas que dice
la gente protestante o no planteaban que
para los protestantes este momento era
muy difícil porque la desunión con una
inglaterra que inglaterra dentro no
europea era atractivo para ellos
inglaterra por aaron europea en oro y
por lo tanto ahora nos enfrentamos a una
crisis constitucional porque hay una
constitución de una ley orgánica porque
determina la situación no cumplir con la
ley no es que va a ir revertir la
violencia no me pagarés me parece porque
haya habido más de una generación que he
estado en esa lógica aunque dice la que
utilizan la violencia para alcanzar
distintos fines políticos es decir ni
bueno ni malo es victoria del país pero
dentro de esa compra en este momento hay
que aguardar unos pocos días a ver cómo
las aguas se calman lo que sí ha habido
en irlanda y eso si los cerebros es que
ha habido ya casi 25 años de aprender a
hablar entre todos los grupos sociales y
eso no indica que se va a perder en este
momento por lo tanto los irlandeses las
mujeres y hombres de bien en la política
debe encontrar una solución
doctor usted no lo menciona una crisis
política prácticamente la vuelta de la
esquina qué posición tienen ahí puntos
clave bruselas que ya dijo que no tienen
nada que negociar de este protocolo de
irlanda qué posición tiene londres qué
posición tiene dublín y belfast al
respecto sobre una posible negociación o
una crisis política que se desate a
través de esta negativa del dv bueno en
mi impresión que intenta liderar la
conversación porque yo el que interesa
un movimiento que le que ese tema o del
número poder así que sin fin para
liderar entonces
el debate interno de inglaterra no es de
fortaleza sino es muy complejo yo viví
cinco años en el reino unido y creo que
bajó por y johnson y todos los problemas
que tienen esta coyuntura política es el
proyecto político del partido
conservador
pues no está en una cautela para no
debilitarse y no convocar unas
elecciones prematuramente que pueda
hacer un cambio político
dentro de esa conversación bruselas
tienen cosas que atender deudas que
pagar y obligaciones económicas que
estudian cómo el conflicto entraña y
dentro de eso creo que en mi impresión
la pasión protestante es no no es esta
debilidad tiene como digo
típico escaño y con eso tiene una
conversación a seguir es decir no es
fuerte pues claro pero qué pasa es que
cultural 20 eso lo que quiero matizar el
conflicto y lander cual por muchas
razones de deportes y tomó seguido
porque históricamente por torrico ha
estado muy vinculado irlanda pero por
otro lado precisamente de 96 el 2000
trabajé aquí para que allí y ahora
cuando uno vuelve creo que es un momento
de una confusión temporera la fuerza que
debe capitalizar en este momento en mi
interés a un precio base el chip pain
porque es histórico lo que ha pasado y
tiene el momento de aunar fuerzas a
partir de una audición creativa de la
unión europea estación creativa que se
la da algún tipo unificación con el sur
porque lo va a hacer con doctor eso de
terminar este tiempo seguir pero ya
estoy un poco más allá de la mitad del
programa
el doctor ni quiero que hablemos de la
estrategia que tuvo sin fin para dar ese
cambio para lograr convencer a más
votantes en estas elecciones y poder
acercarse a otros de sectores de la
sociedad norirlandesa más allá de los
trabajadores que era prácticamente su
base electoral comienzo por en la ciudad
de londres cómo fue ese cambio de
estrategia que tanto influye la imagen
de michelle o'neal en este cambio
estratégico
pues como comentaba antes por la
inteligencia que han tenido de hablar de
las cuestiones que realmente importan a
los ciudadanos al final en cualquier
proceso electoral en gran parte del
mundo de lo que se habla es del coste de
la vida de lo que se habla de la
vivienda de lo que se habla son de
oportunidades laborales y al sinn fein
como decía antes tuvo la astucia de
querer capitalizar ese debate cuando el
pp mantuvo una postura cruzada más
encajada en el problema que ellos tenían
que era el protocolo de irlanda del
norte- entonces al final el duende pp no
es quien no mostrase continuidad o
cambio simplemente estaba encajado en
una cuestión cuando el sinn fein
demostraba dinamismo y eso dinamismo es
un poco el que ha logrado movilizar al
electorado y esta movilización es la que
le ha dado ese pequeño impulso que
necesitaba porque recordemos no hay
tanta diferencia entre los dos partidos
son dos escaños es prácticamente
residual pero es lo que importa está al
final el ganador y el ganador es del
sinn fein y es el que lleva la batuta
estoy de acuerdo con el doctor en que
tiene que estar el sinn fein el que
ahora demuestre que efectivamente ellos
tienen una agenda más allá de lo que es
unificación que había sido su discurso
histórico y ya no lo tiene que demostrar
pero tienen un programa grave ellos no
pueden gobernar en solitario no es como
en otros países que uno puede exponerse
a que siempre sea derrotado en
votaciones parlamentarias porque no
cuenta con mayoría absoluta aquí es
imposible la formación en un gobierno si
el dv nor no acepta si el pp no cumple
su parte que es la de efectivamente
decir bien somos el número 2 hagámoslo y
garantizamos que irlanda del norte-
fructifica de la manera que necesitamos
y sobre todo porque efectivamente había
muchos proyectos en movimiento a partir
de ahí si dentro de seis meses el
electorado tiene que volver a las urnas
porque el dv paralizó todo quizá puedan
acabar pagándolo porque efectivamente a
los ciudadanos cuando en un contexto
como la actual que estamos con un 10 por
ciento de inflación en reino unido lo
que les preocupa es llegar a fin de mes
y eso llegar a fin de mes cuando el
gobierno está paralizado y están
hablando de esencias que quizá a pie de
calle importan menos podría pagarlos de
bp y eso es algo que inteligentemente el
sinn fein puede volver a aprovechar qué
es
centrarse en las cuestiones que importan
la ciudadanía dejar al de siempre ser el
partido un poco de la oposición el
enfadado y ver qué ocurre a partir de
ahí ha sido sobre todo eso la
inteligencia de capitalizar lo que
importa al ciudadano
doctor hablemos de la figura de michelle
o'neal una mujer joven
inmersa en la política norirlandesa un
cambio completamente radical viéndolo
los antecedentes políticos que tiene
esta formación que representa a ella
como tal para este partido el simple
hecho que no esté ligada al ir a jaap
representa un punto de ruptura grande
como lo analiza usted
yo lo lamento es parte de una serie de
televisión que es buenísima que tome el
vídeo el nombre de unas niñas e irlanda
del norte que viven bien en sus puertas
en la escuela lo otro y de repente lo
que me marca a mí todos los cambios
culturales su preocupación política no
es sólo el estatus en por inglaterra
sino somos otros asuntos como voy a
hacer mi futuro porque voy a hacer este
te da esa preocupación viene de los
acuerdos de fan desde el 98 y viene de
la guerra que se libró desde 1972 hasta
el 2000 hasta 1995 básicamente pero
dentro de esa conversación creo que o
brian o'neill
pues la idea para todos nosotros la
narrativa de que no hay una vinculación
con el pasado pues no necesariamente
porque el pasado ya fue pasado y es un
momento de recomponer el país porque
creo y escuchando la compañera analista
y cuando estuve ahora que estuve en los
dos lados estoy viendo muy frecuente
irlanda y veo lo que está pasando pienso
que el espejo más atractivo para la
gente de los tres municipios y c's
gentes es irlanda la repubblica que
tiene un desarrollo macroeconómico
impresionante y es una puerta de éxito
en el diálogo como otra europa que tiene
otros problemas por lo tanto para
o'brien
o'neal para un nervio unidos michelle
unas conversaciones en cambios
culturales lo que veo en esa serie de
televisión y dow en tantas cosas de
partido interesantes irlanda vivió un
cambio cultural que permite superar la
vieja guardia y mantenemos
históricamente ligado en esa vía agua ya
pero no necesariamente es un referente a
seguir es decir el referente es la paz
gerente de consumo en la mercadotecnia
el perder 30 y un crecimiento económico
pero no es necesariamente los murales
impresionantes que hay en webs rojas en
los dos campamentos fijados por la
frontera
que es donde uno de esos murales que son
el principal atractivo turístico no es
lo que han hecho en las viviera allí
desde el espacio e ir a ver los murales
que hay gente que son paseadores son
guías turísticos de tela pasa pero esto
es el pasado ahora creo que ella plantea
un futuro que es tu mejor espejo no es
ella soy más atractivo tiene un espejo
de irlanda la repubblica que es muy
atractivo para el islandés del norte
aquí en américa latina conversando con
algunos de los televidentes a través de
las redes sociales muchos muchos se
mostraron muy
interesados en conocer un poco más en
profundidad ese debate nacional que ha
despertado precisamente michel o'neal
hay en irlanda del norte después de los
resultados de estos comicios ya se
debate nacional sobre una reunificación
con irlanda esto en términos legales yo
sé que usted es periodista puede que no
conozca a profundidad la ley de este
país pero es viable un referendo un
proceso de reunificación en el mediano o
largo plazo esto es viable puede que
londres lo permita esto como puede
transitar
pues esto está todo recogido en la ley
aquí cubrir reino unido significa
conocernos la ley y habernos estudiado
los acuerdos de viernes santo pues bien
está muy claro en qué momento tiene que
haber este potencial referente de
unificación bien de acuerdo con los
acuerdos de viernes santo es cuando está
claro que hay un cambio social que apoya
potencialmente una reunificación como se
nota un cambio social lógicamente sólo
en un reparto de escaños entonces el
otro día escuchábamos a la presidenta
del sinn fein que es mal y lou mcdonald
también la mujer con un perfil muy
interesante igual que el de michelle
o'neal son dos personas como decía el
doctor completamente ajenas a la vieja
guardia y esto es lo que ha ayudado
muchísimo pues bien mal un mcdonald que
es la que ha sustituido al famoso gerry
adams aquella persona tan tan vinculada
para bien o para mal con él irá ha dicho
que en un plazo de cinco años podríamos
plantear la posibilidad de un referéndum
sin embargo aquí la última palabra la
tiene el gobierno británico y el
gobierno británico y ha dicho que ahora
mismo él parto parlamentario muestra
aquí un 58 por ciento de fuerzas
políticas o bien apoyan la continuidad
en reino unido o no quieren un cambio
constitucional con lo cual de momento no
se darían lo que a quien reinó unido- se
conocen como las condiciones favorables
para la celebración de un referéndum que
es aquí algo de momento pues
completamente remoto hasta que esté muy
claro y sólo puede estar muy claro por
ejemplo pues sin un parlamento de 90
escaños como es el de irlanda del norte
de repente al sinn fein logra 58 escaños
ahí estaría claro que lógicamente un
partido que apoya la reunificación con
irlanda gana hasta ese nivel estamos
hablando de que la ciudadanía
lógicamente no le hace ascos a la
posibilidad de una unificación con
irlanda de momento no parece que estamos
en ese escenario porque efectivamente ya
no sólo la división de las dos fuerzas
políticas 26 escaños y 25 sino que hay
otras fuerzas políticas y la unión de
esas fuerzas políticas es 58 por ciento
no necesariamente están de acuerdo con
una reunificación con lo cual es algo
remoto de momento
remoto queda queda claro eva gracias por
esa explicación me queda un minuto de
programa por favor necesito hacer las
conclusiones de lo que vendrá para
irlanda del norte para este momento
político que está viviendo comienzo con
el doctor ni ná doctor un minuto por
favor puntual
muy bien puntual ello el primer momento
en 1916 fue el lunes santo el lunes
primero de la semana santa y el momento
de conclusión fue el viernes santo es
interesante no sólo son espirituales
sino que es un pueblo que a partir de su
cosmovisión religiosa han logrado muchas
cosas podemos discrepar podemos en este
momento después de un cambio
generacional que es lo que estoy
marcando han pasado ya 25 años ese
cambio generacional esta visión negra va
a marcar un futuro racional de diálogo
no preveo en este momento lo contrario
no están puestas para eso si un momento
que o no que tenemos mucho por las
condiciones materiales lleva 30 segundos
para la conclusión
la conclusión es que el gobierno
británico realmente va a saber que
decida porque ahora ha decidido
descartar muchas partes del famoso
protocolo de irlanda del norte que es el
gran bloqueo para el partido de upe a
partir de ahí si los satisfacen el de bp
no tendrá otra opción que formar
gobierno con el sinn fein porque esos
son lo que establecen las pautas
democráticas así que tenemos que ver lo
que hace en londres en las próximas
semanas ahí vaya el doctor ni ná les
agradezco muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia france24 en
américa latina' ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales pueden
seguir también con la programación de
france 24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]